firstly I'd like to say welcome to the
first meeting of the new baby cabinet
I particularly want to welcome back
returning councillors Osborne and Davis
and give a a welcome also to back to the
cabinet after an absence to councillor
Parker and a particular welcome to our
new cabinet members councillor Bob
ec-council Aarthi and councillor Busby
the last one in the castle Holt is still
away on holiday but he'll be back for
the next meeting before we go on I just
want to mention that this meeting is
going to be broadcast live via YouTube
and that's the entirety of the meeting
except for any confidential or exempt
items which we don't have today so I
have to assume that everyone's given
their consent to being photographed and
their voice is recorded finally the
council members of the public and the
press may recall film or photograph or
broadcasters meeting when the public and
the press are not lawfully excluded
right moving on into the meeting itself
firstly apologies for absence thank you
declaration of interest by councillors
any interested members
no thank you and next item to receive
phonetically notification sorry minutes
got minutes
firstly go through the minutes of the
cabinet meeting we held on Thursday 7th
of March for your review and
completeness page 1 page 2 page 3
page four oh sorry cat suave CIS okay um
1 3 2 1 3 2 1 first bullet is that 64
pounds or 64,000 we're guessing that's
lost one inch of East 64 thousand yeah
yes good spot given that it was 84
that's page 4 page 5 and could I ask
what be mbss cuz I couldn't find any
reference to it in the fourth survey for
a mid Suffolk building services thank
you and then one 32.7 like that at the
end of the first line that oh yes I
think we only need one that thank you
okay thank you
page six
page 7 page 8 page 9 yes one 34.6
counselor Davis stated it was important
that schools were supported and it was
also important important was that it was
for the wider community yeah okay needs
to tighten up on yep sentence there yeah
okay thank you
page 10 and Council Awards date is that
the overall cost estimates have been
reduced and that in this case approval
should be granted but agreed but no
delete the but three min ago I'm taking
through to that okay thank you thank you
page 11 page 12 page 13 I'm back again
reason for decision last sentence these
decisions relating to the expenditure of
SIL monies form one of the ways the that
needs to be deleted one of the ways by
which yeah and then one three five point
one third sentence down four fifth line
up the service had been operating
successfully for over a year and had
been effective now it should be
effective yes thank you
page 14 page 15 page 16 yeah me again
what at least seven point four I believe
that on the second line it should be
inserted reading forward and that it was
very important because it doesn't really
make much sense and then one three seven
point seven yep
we have over bath showers not over
shower baths yeah yeah and then further
along on that line replace that with who
because we're talking about people are
you okay and again on one three seven
point one point one zero last line
replace effect with effect yes okay page
eighteen page 19 all right page 18 okay
and one three seven point one six cancel
Osborne commended the team for their
hard work and innovative thinking
18 19 20
and finally page 21 okay may I have a
proposal in second two for the minutes
as amended by a councillor VC may have a
proposer and seconder for the minutes
all those in favor of adopting the
minutes you are they okay thank you
everyone
right moving on then now to receive
notifications and petitions in
accordance with the castle's petition
scheme received questions by councillors
thank you and matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees thank you next item
is the forthcoming decisions list you've
all been emailed a copy of that have you
had okay I've just been informed that
paper copies are on their way out but
has everyone had a chance to look at the
copy that was emailed
you prefer to do that you don't have a
copy on your laptop if you'd like to
defer this item until after the next one
while we're waiting we're like it we'll
take it we'll take it later then moving
on then item eight and that's paper BCA
nineteen to the general fund financial
out turn for 2018 to 2019
so this report presents the 2018 to 2019
out turn for the general fund revenue
account and the general fund capital
program as always a reporting by
exception approach has been adopted our
strategic response to financial
challenges summarizing the key 5 in the
5 key actions in paragraph 4.1 is
continuing to be successful the good
news is that we have an improved surplus
position since the April to December
monitoring report that we looked at in
March the key thing to note is that
despite the improve position expenditure
is in line with budget but the surplus
being due to additional income received
most of this being a one-off so for the
revenue account there is a 2 point 2 8 1
million pound favorable variance by a
surplus which is an improvement of 1
point 4 5 2 million since the previous
report the key variations on expenditure
and income compared with the budget have
been identified and are presented in the
table in paragraph 5.4 the breakdown of
the one point 452 million pound change
and these are all favorable items is 846
thousand pounds income from the business
rate section 31 grants but it is worth
noting that this is double what we would
normally receive due to the council
being part of the business rates
retention pilot scheme which was for
2018-19 only two hundred eighty-seven
thousand pounds of revenue and benefits
and this is mostly Housing Benefit 171
thousand pounds recharged to the HRA in
capital one hundred and twelve thousand
pounds planning fee income and a net 36
thousand pounds favorable change for
other
full details of the the befall to 2.2 81
million pound surplus are included
within the table in Section 5.4 of the
report which includes the April to
December variances for comparison and
the highlights all of which are
favorable are one point eight four six
million pounds of business rates
including the additional six and thirty
one grants two hundred eighty seven
thousand pounds for revenue and benefits
one hundred and fifty nine thousand
pounds reduced expenditure on the joint
local plan ninety four thousand pounds
for the SIL five percent admin charge in
one hundred and nine thousand pounds for
waste services the finally one hundred
eighty five thousand pounds if going
come but against these positive numbers
there are still some worrying increased
adverse variances for instance the PV
panels ICT and mainly for Skype costs
and also grounds maintenance these were
mentioned last time and the situation is
not unfortunately improving yet for our
reserves I'm pleased to report that the
overall picture means that our earmark
reserves are a much healthier nine point
six million pounds which is five point
seven million excluding SIL a
significant improvement on a year ago
and these are shown in Appendix C
Reserve movements to know as detailed in
section five point seven a one point
eight four six million pounds to the
beast business rates equalization
Reserve which is a further increased to
this particular reserve two hundred
ninety three thousand pounds to the
transformation fund one hundred fifty
nine thousand pounds to the joint local
plan reserve and one hundred and forty
three thousand pounds net transfer to
other earmarked reserves there are also
a few carry forward requests totally in
seventy four thousand pounds as shown in
paragraph five point eight with regard
to the transformation fund that the
current projects are listed in Appendix
B were those still open identified in
red in the various column you'll be
pleased to see in section five point
nine that the transformation fund after
accounting for outstanding commitments
will have three hundred and thirty five
thousand pounds in it which is a much
better position than the twenty five
thousand pounds that we last saw for the
capital program you'll see that there's
seven hundred and twenty seven thousand
pounds over spend but the reasons for
this are summarized at paragraph five
point four one for the capital program
is
set out in full in appendix D the
overspend broken down as follows
there's 1.055 million pound tsypko
adverse variance due to the additional
10% contingency that was requested
there's a two hundred thirty six
thousand pounds favorable favorable
variance for the grounds for empty homes
and in ninety nine thousand pounds
payroll variance for ICT this ninety two
thousand pounds favorable variance for
Community Grants and for other items
there is a net forty forty two thousand
pounds adverse variance the total
overspend includes contractual
commitments of two hundred ninety six
thousand pounds and seven point eight
five million pounds of carry forwards
and these are shown in paragraphs five
point one five and five point one six in
terms of contractual commitments
there's maton mandatory disability
facilities grants of one hundred sixty
six thousand pounds and community
development grants at one hundred and
thirty thousand pounds in terms of carry
forwards we've got land assembly
property acquisition and regeneration
opportunities totaling six point six
three five million pounds laser centers
837 thousand pounds grants for
affordable housing four hundred thousand
pounds
ICT 160,000 pounds play equipment with
fifty thousand pounds and planned
maintenance for corporate buildings of
thirty eight thousand pounds
so therefore when coming to the
recommendations I propose the
recommendations of paragraph 3 of the
report three point one with the 2018 to
nineteen financial out Turner set out
and this report be noted three point two
that the following net transfers of two
point two eight 1 million pounds be
noted firstly transferred to reserves of
one hundred forty three thousand pounds
being the net amount for the specific
EMR preserves referred to in Section
five point seven and Appendix C in this
report and secondly of the remaining
balance of the general fund surplus one
point eight four six million pounds to
be transferred to the business rates
equalization Reserve and two hundred
ninety three thousand pounds to the
transformation fund as referred to in
Section two point one C three point
three that the general fund carry
forward requests totaling 75,000 pounds
refer to and paragraph five point eight
of this report
proved three point four that the total
capital carry forward requests referred
to in paragraph five point sixteen of
this report totaling seven point eight
five million pounds be approved and
there is a reasons for the decision is
to ensure that members are kept informed
of the outcome position for both general
fund reserve and capital and also to
approve the carry forward requests
thank you may I have a seconder
councillor Osborn members of the cabinet
do you have any questions councillor
Busby number on presentation primarily
on page 26 I have discussed this week
with John we have a table which shows
the difference to budget and we talked
about two point two eight 1 million
pounds total variance and the tables
below that's supposed to be an
explanation of that but it's very
difficult to work out where I mean for
instance the first heading in the table
is strategic planning which doesn't
appear in the table above there isn't
anything that says be a mess invest in
these tables which relates to the first
line of the other table it's just
impossible to to marry up the figures on
I think I'm housing revenue account II
it does do that it's easy to follow also
the layout is strange in this we've got
garden hose only 20 paise all of these
10 pages of explanation most of we say
either it's a favorable variant or an
adverse variance and there's a movement
on last time you can show that in the
figures if each item within each box
will show that a figure you wouldn't
need anything else you could get all
that information on one page
and as you can see that it's going to be
a feature of my discussion this morning
as we proceed through the meeting if
anybody's still listening
yeah so I think we just need to look at
the presentation of this first first
part of the report a question on five
one six page 39 we in the table there
we've got this land assembly property
acquisition and regeneration opportunity
6.4 million could somebody explain where
that came from and have we got any ideas
how we're going to be spending in I'll
pass that over behind me I think Kathryn
or Melissa in a second but I do believe
that a number of individual individual
budgets have been identified as that
correctly this refers to but before
actually Kathryn answers on your first
point about presentation and layout that
is something that we are going to be
working on and I will be talking to
about that so we'll be presenting it in
a different format to the next time you
see it when we look at the first quarter
for the current financial year but if I
can pass over to Kathryn on that
particular question
thank you chair and yet the figure of
6.4 million has built up I think over
perhaps or two or three year period
because Bebo did have an annual
allocation of about 2.7 million I think
in its capital program so that hasn't
been used but it is it's building up to
enable Baber to do some of the
investments that is wanting to do so
some of this money could be used towards
the headquarters building being
redeveloped and the money source it's
within Emily a tax area so I'm guessing
Emily will be talking to you as the
cabinet member for assets and
investments about the use of that money
going forward and what it seemed artful
okay any other questions anyone Cussler
Aarthi yeah it's not really a question
as a couple of comments really first the
budgeting is all about predicting income
and expenditure so in a way this report
is saying how we got it a bit wrong but
we got it a bit wrong in the right way
if you know what I mean
so we've ended up with a bit more money
than we thought rather than a bit less
but I've always been a believer that
good budgeting means that your answer
and actually is fairly close to your
budgeted figure as you know I've had
quite a few questions on this all of
which have been answered but I have got
a new one which is I think I mentioned
it before
it's about Grants and it's on page 38
and 39 I think I mentioned the grants
for empty homes once before but adding
that so the community groans it appears
that there's over three hundred thousand
pounds of grant money that we've had
available to hand out which hasn't been
used and I just wonder whether that
actually means that we're not being very
successful at attracting bids if you
like for people to use this money we've
made it available and I don't know if
there's anybody that can comment on that
first of all in terms of your your
initial comment about the the budget
numbers overall as I did say when when I
introduced it the expenditure is in
actually in line with our budget
predictions that the the increased
favorable position is purely because of
these unexpected or largely due to these
unexpected section 31 grants as a result
of the business retention pilot so
apart from that the the the budgeting
process is is accurate and I think you
was certainly we won't see that in
future years because we were not part of
it
we were only part of that pilot for one
year for 2018-2019 but in terms of the
grants I take a point that the chief
executive would like to pick up on that
I trying to sit on the table the year
482 which is table and a 5.15 that's
simply a reflection of being the end of
the year so we take an artificial point
in time and obviously we report to you
in a particular point in time and it
happens to be end of the financial year
monies are committed in the previous
year they haven't actually gone out the
door yet because for the sake of
argument if somebody's building and I'll
take the extreme example we're building
a village all you commit an amount of
money in community grant towards that
funding of that community all but
obvious it's reliant upon other funds
being generated from other places you've
earmark to the funding but it isn't
drawn down and other things actually
built so you will have that that lag
that will happen at any point to the
epitopes it shows up more significantly
when you move from one financial year
into the other similarly with disabled
facility grants the monies may well have
been allocated to have a works done to
somebody's home but that work hasn't yet
been carried out and so you'll always
have a lag between the committed some
and the actual spend going out the door
could I follow up on that then I mean I
think I've probably misunderstood it I'm
not sure in five 14 the penultimate
bullet points at the top of page 39 it
says about community grants following a
review of the grants allocation process
only expenditure that is genuinely
committed will be carried forward
resulting in a favorable variance of 92
that I've read that to mean that there's
92,000 that is not going to be carried
forward and is not committed
that's right they're two different
things so what you've got in five 14 is
not the same as the numbers you were
looking at under five fifteen no quite
but to be fair my question was about
five fourteen krantz for empty homes at
the bottom of page 38 and community
grants at top of page 39 so that that
92,000 day and I mean that that
basically as far as being available for
grant applications is concerned that was
gone now hasn't it Catherine come back
on it yes that isn't being proposed to
carry forward that's obviously the
discussions that finance have had with
the corporate manager in that area but
there will be there is a new allocation
in the current year
so there are spawn still available but
they felt that there wasn't a need for
that particular element to be carried
forward into the current year I think
come on to the more general point about
community grants and that is that they
haven't been taken up I mean in the old
days we used to have lots and lots and
lots of applications we didn't have
enough money and we had to decide which
which bids we were going to support now
it appears to be that we have community
grants available that are not being
handed out is that because we're too
strict about the criteria it would make
it's so difficult for people or is it
that people are accessing funding from
other places from our own point of view
perhaps self funding so that this this
sort of like pot of money that we've set
aside is not being called upon from my
point of view I think it probably that
the latter has some some impact there
are a number of sources of funding
heritage funding a lottery funding SIL
funding and but we did we try our best
to to point people to our community
grants that we can offer here it's and
members have to help with that as well
making sure that they their communities
are are aware of what's on offer but
we could we can only provide the grants
when when applications come in but I
don't know anymore about the reasons why
they're long coming forward if I just
add to that so in the absence of Tom
Barker I wouldn't want to speculate it's
the actual reasoning what I would say is
you adopted a new community strategy
just before the elections fundamentally
part and part of that is looking at how
you use your grand schemes to best
effect in relation to that community
strategy so I would expect to see that
change in the course of the year and be
brought back to you and with the answer
to your question as well castle Davis
yeah thanks this is within my portfolio
I might get to add a little bit more
further to what has just said regarding
the strategy and but also yeah Tommy's
on leave at the moment but we're already
looking at ways of helping and
improvement within the communities
Department because there have been some
changes and we're looking to move
forward on that and if I can give you an
example which is mentioned in here the
disabled facilities grant which is
slightly different as a housing we've
already taken steps to change the
criteria on that so it's actually easier
for people to access so it's no longer
means-tested up to 5,000 pounds and
we've already had a good take up on that
so steps are being taken to to make
things a little bit easier and the other
thing is again that's been mentioned as
board members do play a part in this and
and and whereas we used to have locality
officers that's not there at the moment
but that's something that Tom and Kathy
are exploring as well so we're looking
to move things forward in that respect
Thank You Council that's great Thank You
councillor Osborne
yeah also on the question about the
grants for entry homes the the team are
doing a lot of work on getting a take-up
of the grants that are available to
landlords to bring those empty
properties back into use however
obviously more work needs to be done but
we are very conscious that the private
landlord plays a very big role in
delivering homes so we are what the team
are working very hard on how they can
progress get
more uptake from private landlords to go
for those grounds any other questions
Castle Busby page 43 appendix B
transformation fund line five got
additional economic development capacity
to support a number of initiatives and
apparently we've got a eighty-seven
thousand pounds we haven't spent which
was saying he's no longer required
I'm surprised we can't find something so
just to be clear and coming back to the
question about budgeting and that's
eight seven thousand pounds that wasn't
required in relation to that original
plan in terms of budgeting I'm sure as
councillors you'll always find reasons
to spend money in that regard but we
wouldn't wish to do that outside of the
process in terms of bringing that back
to you for decision-making but I've seen
the economic development team not
identified projects that you know could
use them if not why not absolutely will
and a half done so but that was in
relation to those specific projects that
it was originally earmarked for so there
will be other projects that could be
funded absolutely any other questions
rose water Thank You mr. chairman it's
more a statement actually than a
question on page 27 revenues and
benefits it's looking really good on
that budget and that is down to the
shared revenue partnership and I'd like
to commend the team for their
performance on that I sit on the shared
revenue partnership and we see we go we
have reports every three months and
they're getting more and more positive
each report that comes forward so I'd
like to commend that team on their
performance thank you
anyone else capsule McCraw do you have a
question no okay well members of the
cabinet if there are no more questions
or comments on on the general fund our
turn the recommendations have been
proposed and seconded may have take a
vote on it please all those in favor
thank you
okay moving on to the next item it is
paper BCA 19 3 the housing ribbon your
current financial outcome for 2018 to 19
this this will come under the finance
portfolio going forward but in this
transition I'm going to let counsel
oddball and present this paper for the
last time Thank You mr. chairman I'm
pleased to now introduce the report
which covers the out turn for 2018 19 of
our ring-fenced housing revenue account
the housing revenue account is currently
reporting and under spend for the year
a4 491 K which is 247 K higher than the
budget the individual variances for the
year are reported in the table in note
5.6 with the way what main ones being
repairs and maintenance and adverse
variance of 660 a K of which 606 K is
attributed to beta and mid Suffolk
building services due to timing
differences on jobs being carried out
and recharged to the relevant service
areas and the work undertaken to reduce
the number of void days resulting in an
increased use of external contractors
responsive repairs and adverse variants
amounting to 147 K due to increase in
material costs and the number of repairs
being carried out these have been
partially offset by a very favorable
variance of 85 K for void repairs due to
the real
location of costs to capital property
services an adverse variance of 247 K of
which 138 K is attributable to planned
maintenance heating and 93 K to asbestos
surveys due to an increase in material
costs and the work required to be
carried out sheltered housing is 23 K
adverse due to higher than anticipated
Legionella
Legionella testing on Elizabeth Court
sorry that's quite a mouthful
depreciation 109 km erst as costs were
higher than anticipated within the
business model due to the more stock
than anticipated and higher property
values the opposite effect of this will
be to increase the funds available in
the major repairs reserve these adverse
variances have been offset by a
favorable variance of 1.9 to 8 million
in respect of the revenue contribution
required to fund capital outlay this is
a favorable movement of 361 K since the
last report due to the increase in
funding from major repairs reserves
mentioned previously and utilizing more
capital receipts than anticipated on the
capital we are reporting a favorable
variance of 599 K for the year as
described in note 5.12 the main reasons
for this variance are capital
maintenance is showing a 72 K minor
favorable variance ICT 344 k variable
variance due to staff costs now being
allocated to revenue new-build 162 k
variable variance which is a large
adverse movement of 3.1 million from the
last report this is due to carry forward
to funds to be utilized against
developments that will be completed in
2019 20 reserves the increase in the
surplus on the revenue account means
that the static priorities reserve will
in
prove by 491 k to 12 point 1 million a
new earmarked reserve has been created
for the building council home program
grant amounting to 20k prior to
answering any members questions on the
report I'd first like to move the
recommendations set out in section 3 on
page 47 of the report that the out turn
be noted the 491 case up to speed
transferred to the reserves and the
capital carry forward requests be
approved Thank You mr. chairman Thank
You councillor may I have a seconder for
that councillor Davis members of the
cabinet do you have any questions on the
HRA financial out zone
no sir are theay again not really
questions they're more comments the
first one I have had an explanation from
councillor Osborn about it in the past
but I would just like to highlight it
it's page 49 bottom bullet point about
rental income and garage rents this of
course highlights a problem we have that
we have garages that nobody wants to
rent and I understand we are
opportunities to build homes on some of
my garage sites which I'm pleased to
hear the other comment that I was going
to make was the good news
this is page 53 bad death provision the
final bullet points at the table the
good news really that the implementation
of universal credit has not had the
impact on bad debts that we'd
anticipated so I mean that's obviously
gone a little bit more easily than we
thought it happened certainly a little
bit more easily than the Press reported
it would be so that's that's quite good
yes I was encouraged to see that as well
and also the fact that we've got that
nice 2% recovery of outstanding arrears
which is it's quite a good achievement
so I think that's a very good good
cancer Osbourne yeah on that on that a
point of universal credit that again is
down due to very proactive and creating
working prior to the implementation of
universal credit in Baber and there's
still a lot of more work to be done
don't think we can underestimate the
impact that universal credit may
continue to have in the nineteen twenty
budget but that is down to a lot of
creative working by the team prior to
the implementation of it so again
they're to be commended Thank You
councillor Busby thank you page 49 table
at the top you referred to be mb/s being
an adverse event to six hundred six
thousand in a year and we look at the
top second line down repairs and
maintenance over 40 percent over budget
six hundred and seventy thousand maybe I
can't believe that a any building
company that's got a budget at 1.7
million could suddenly 403 quarters a
million pounds to spend extra why are we
doing that I mean either it was very
poor budgeting or very poor management
in terms of how we spent that budget and
the next line down property services
were 25% over over on that as well big
concern it's not general fund but even
service large amounts to be overspent on
a budget yeah I'm happy to talk about
those stickers in relation to building
services members over the last year have
scrutinized that service including
through the cabinet overview in scrutiny
and there has been an internal audit of
the business plan and the business plan
has been revised for this year going
forward I think is important to note
that in the comments it does highlight
that a large amount of that additional
spent which was unforeseen was due to
the use of external contractors and that
was as a result with the void
project which members set as a key
priority to reduce void time from what
were 60 plus days some 12 18 months ago
and are now down on average to less than
20 that was a target set by members and
as a result there was a need to bring in
external contractors to support with
that project we don't see the need for
external contractors carrying out our
work in the future I think it's also
important to note the benefits that that
void project has had in regards to the
reduction in void times means more
rental income a quick calculation based
on average council rents per day based
on the void reduction times that you've
seen equates to sixty eight thousand
pounds of additional rental income and
that's a side to the increase in council
tax that we receive and that we don't
have to contribute towards when
probably's avoid reductions in B&B costs
because potentially if those people that
sadly find themselves homeless and are
looking for homes or in B&B and also the
social benefit of not seeing empty
property set m.d on our estates for
considerable time so I think there's a
lot of positives there I take on board
the pump the points in relation to to
the figures I think there's an
explanation Thank You Gavin yeah
obviously the the numbers have been
discouraging but there have been reasons
for it and things things will will
improve over the next year or two but so
that the points that Gavin has made in
terms of the non-financial benefits of
reducing the void time so that those are
unarguable in my view it's much better
news for us and for those on on the
waiting list that we don't do not have
long void times in our properties and we
keep that down towards those numbers as
we possibly can we want those houses
filled because we want to house people
though there is a demand for housing
and I think that's fully justified this
program custom LBC canceled award I
think you've actually answered my
question because being a newbie and
trying to understand council finances so
basically the cost of the builders in
refurbishing putting right correcting
whatever is wrong with the housing stock
that is sitting empty so there's a lot
of revenue and there's a cost yes
but the cost has been considerable the
increased revenue you buy having people
in those houses sooner the rather than
later in terms of the rental income and
the castle tax yes that has that has
been increased but it hasn't compensated
for the initial cost that we've had to
bear but as but there's Gavin but the
point is Gavin said that there are the
the the social benefits as well which
obviously you can't quantify yes sorry
Gavin
sorry just about a further comment and
and it is a positive in respect of the
additional spending property services
some of that is attributed to the work
that we've been doing around compliance
so anyone living in a council house in
may but can feel safe that or grade free
asbestos has been removed from their
properties majority of all grade to
asbestos will be removed this year and
so the very very lowest level of
asbestos will be be left and we'll have
a program for that that's been an
investment in additional investment
beyond what was programmed and in
addition to that checks around Allegiant
element and so on have we've increased
as well so positive key messages as to
why some of that that's been that's been
attributed this year thank you thanks
any other councillor Busby well
continuing on our on the point I was
raising we didn't we brought building
services into the two councils not long
ago on a set of figures which I thought
were very iffy at the time seem to be
very low in terms of certain costs on
reflection bear in mind that we're 40
percent over budget whatever the reason
would we still consider having those
building services inside is a good
decision or should we revert back to
what they were before which was a all
contracted yes I was warned you want to
come back or not yeah I'd like to come
back and it's an ongoing process that
we're always cutting we know we're
constantly looking at the model for B
MBS looking how it's working and I think
it's fair to say we need to look forward
rather than look back perhaps the most
mistakes were made in the past but now
we need to move forward and there is a
lot of work being done by the team to
make sure that that team is working
efficiently and effectively
for example the culture within the team
the morale within the the operatives and
the actual working practices that they
just make sure it's more efficient and
effective so I think we need to give it
the opportunity to show that it will
work out in the end and the tenants are
very happy with the service that they're
getting from B MBS which is which is the
key point because we recently approved a
business plan for B NBS and the priority
for that was on providing a good service
rather than the income itself so that's
the way we're moving but we are looking
at how we can improve the income and the
expenditure I would agree with that I
think it's a matter of letting it settle
in now and and seeing the benefits of
the pain that we've been through and
those benefits I'm sure will accrue over
the next year or two and and of course
as you pointed out that there is a new
revised and more robust business plan so
I think we've got got a handle on B MBS
and I expect to see improvements going
forward kusmanov AC I know I'm a newbie
but sometimes cost has to be weighed up
again
environmental impact on health and
well-being of heard mention of asbestos
that's a red flag because it in itself
causes problems but I think we also as a
kind of soul we have to bear in mind our
duty of care to our tenants in terms of
the total holistic environmental impact
thank you yes
great okay if there are no more
questions from from the cabinet but one
more from page 50 was just a explanation
reading the top budgets bullet point
under housing management the auditors
have suggested that we now have to take
these agency fees back into revenue
rather than capital can somebody explain
that to me how why it suddenly switched
from one to the other
yeah I can answer that in relation to
there was a significant amount of
capital work required in bringing the
housing management software systems that
both pedra mid Suffolk used together we
were fortunate that both councils used
the same provider but they were used
very differently obviously both councils
are still suffering separate councils
and so that presented challenges for us
frame bringing the housing management
system together to produce those
efficiencies in regards to how people
make mention repairs or how staff may
manage rent arrears within the software
bearing in mind that the money's going
into two separate accounts and and and
that so there was a lot of investment in
officer time and investment in capita to
get that working effectively that was
capital there was then the decision that
actually ongoing costs thereon become a
revenue cost thank you
you okay if they're no more questions
from the cabinet
I believe customer crawl you'd like to
ask a question more of an observation
and based on the experience of scrutiny
looking at on page 53 this has been
referred to by counsel Roz borne the
implementation of universal credit and
as I recall when this came to scrutiny
it had been pointed out but at that
point it's gone much further only 20
percent of the rollout of Universal
Credit applied to this district so we
still have to see what the other 80
percent impact might produce and there
was also a question of the 53 week year
which had not been planned for in the
original planning if that's the work of
universal credit so those impacts only
represent one-fifth of the potential and
I suspect we may see further impacts
later on I just thought that point
should be made but I would agree with
what councilor Osborne said that there's
been a very proactive organization in
preparing for the rollout of universal
credit but the job isn't done over Thank
You councillor McCraw yeah I fully
understand what you're saying and
obviously we will keep a close watch on
it okay members of the cabinet you've
had the recommendations for persons
seconded they take a vote all those in
favor please thank you
moving on now paper BCA 1904 that the
court for performance outcome reporting
and I'd like to ask councillor Parker to
introduce this please thank chance a
pleasure good morning everybody
cabinet members I would like to present
the quarter for performance report to
you which is the final report for the
2018-19 financial year in doing so I'd
like to acknowledge that councillor
Davis was the portfolio holder
responsible for the performance during
this period and I'd like to thank you
counsel Davis for your work in that area
particularly for his work with the
Business Improvement Team in developing
a robust performance framework
it widely reflects the activities of the
council and will continue to report on
measures associated with our key
priorities whilst the report provides a
summary of our performance the
appendices provide greater detail and
trends along with a reflection of some
of the key achievements during the
period I'm delighted that there are many
areas in the report where our
performance exceeds our targets and over
the coming year we'll start to introduce
some benchmarking data wherever possible
I'd like to recommend the cabinet
members agree that the performance
report and the performance outcome
information table that appendices a2h
reflect the council's performance for
January to March thank you thank you
guys sir may I have a seconder for for
that councillor Davis yeah as usual
these reports are very good very
informative I just want to make one
quick observation though we need to
update the cabinet member
responsibilities in the appendices
they've still got the old cabinet
members listed but any questions members
of the cabinet council councillor Busby
the House Rock again it's to do with
these I guess the stars on the length of
the report and it seems to be the
difference between data and information
we're getting a lot of data
I'm not certain it's informational or
knowledge necessarily why what's being
presented I mean I think we turn to page
65 which is Appendix A penny take a lot
of the information I'm not certain that
we we need to have it as an a3 fold out
with six months for the previous two
quarters on that's the last two quarters
will do I don't think they need to know
all that if you go the next page 67
although it's nice to have graphs and
things like that but sometimes it
doesn't actually tell us a great deal I
mean the top one on page 67 they're all
100% so what's the point of having a
graph what's the point of reporting like
quite frankly and again when you start
talking in terms of percentages but
there are small numbers against a bit
meaningless almost just the comments
column would do that would tell us as
much as we need to know and I think
generally you've got to ask the question
why are we getting this is it just for
comfort or is it to get us to do
something about it it should be I think
the latter and then you link those
comments back to the reports and the the
comments in the reports don't actually
again this data not information in my
view if you take the first one the
number of days lost a sickness a number
of staff on long term sickness it it
tells us that it's decreased 22% from
one quarter and 69 percent from the
previous quarter and twenty-five percent
from the previous last year and whatever
it is doesn't actually mean anything if
somebody is somebody has said that the
both indices peaked last September
during the office move which was
understandable and if now the indices
have come back to the level the average
level before that office moved that
would explain what happened and why and
where we are again now it doesn't just
quoting percentages doesn't actually
tell us anything that's my key concern
there and just a volume of paper that
goes with all of this you know it goes
on and on page 73 which is the average
time taken to process council tax
benefit changes you know it looks great
because we're well better than target
the targets to high target of 10 days we
haven't hit 10 we haven't been above 10
day
in the last three years so why have we
had a target of 10 it's down now down to
7
but we're still well below that and
really do we need all of that
information to show that we're averaging
whatever it is 3.9 1% it's just to
thinking of these poor people are having
to do all of the work
let's pop as well as me able to read it
so I just can we review these before we
get to the end of the next quarter and
decide what it is that we're trying to
do here rather than just laborious ly
regurgitate reports okay counselor Busby
I'm going to pass over to councilor
Parker any second now but I will make an
observation I think your your criticism
is not harsh I don't think it's a matter
of data rather than information I think
there's a lot of information there and
indeed you did use that word yourself
just 30 seconds ago so too much
information I think which no no you did
use would have but the point is the
trends whether they're graphical trends
or or template tabulated percentages are
there and it's those that this
information is is there to to give us so
that we can respond to those trends so I
think this it's giving us a lot of
useful information not just data but I
will pass over to counsel Parker and
thank you Chennai to effect you said
exactly what I was gonna say nothing
with respect to councillor Busby he's
actually mentioned a number of points
there actually so I and I take the point
actually with regards to maybe the
presentation that you know these are
sort of large bits of paper so you know
it's it's our job as cabinet members to
to make sure that you know that we want
things to be presented by the way that
presented so that they're clear and
they're legible Matt and I take that on
board and I'm sure that's something that
we can go back and perhaps give
consideration to with regards to the
information that's contained within the
reports however
I
I probably will disagree with him
counselor Busbee I think that it's it's
it's right and proper that we have a
wealth of information at our hands some
of that information is ready readily
available for people when they request
it to be honest I think it would be easy
if we didn't have the information I'm
sure the criticism would be that we
haven't got the information so yeah
absolutely if you put data in data will
come out so you know it's I'm sorry that
we've reached 100 percent target on
everything but but I don't apologize for
the fact that we will report on that but
but I do I mean it's it's interesting
that you mentioned for example the
number of days lost to sickness now I'm
quite sure being a newbie myself to this
I'm quite sure that if we drill down on
that we actually do know what the what
the underlying figures are under there
I'm quite sure of it
but I do take your point I've an actual
fact I asterisks exactly the same thing
when I was reading through the through
the report myself you know a percentage
of what so yeah I think in summary I
take on board what you're saying and yes
I think will will will review your
comments the information contained
therein however I don't make any
apologies for okay in that case since
you're all fully behind all the reports
perhaps you could explain page 93 and
what benefit we're getting from that one
[Applause]
it's the ax hpo4 movement on the housing
register if I can check if that's the
right and look I take the point
councillor Busby and again it comes down
to presentation if you if you put data
in you get data out but I take your
point and I would be interested to hear
the officers comment with regards to
page 93 particularly if anybody's got
any comments they can often I suspect
Gavin might want to provide answer to
that but I'm gonna cheat slightly if I
may and take the floor just to cover a
couple of things if I can so these are
your performance reports come back to
council Busby's point and particularly
they're your performance reports as
cabinet members so as the cabinet member
responsible for whichever section if you
don't like it change it because I
absolutely take the point that I don't
want to produce information or data or
analysis for you that you don't want
having said that there's also a
collective knowledge that comes from
this and it's not just knowledge for the
cabinet it's knowledge for all
councilors and it's not just knowledge
for all councilors is all it's knowledge
for the public as well so it's covering
covering a multitude of of bases in that
regard
and I suspect and Gavin may want to add
but for example page 93 one of the
things that we're regularly asked about
by lots of counselors is how BIG's the
housing waiting register list and what
bandings and how is that moving around
and so I suspect that's there for that
purpose were would absolutely I might be
looking a different page to you because
I'm looking at the digital version and
that was the other thing I was going to
encourage all members to do because I've
heard a couple of references to paper
you are all in a position to walk pit
outs from receiving paper
unfortunately ridiculously you do
actually have to opt out so I would
encourage you looking around looking at
the whole series of electronic devices
to encourage before courage you before
you leave this room to opt-out from that
paper and that would immediately assist
in that respect but and it would also
assist in terms of the fact that patient
and brings do vary depending with you
whether you're looking at the digital
version of the paper
I may not have answer the question
you're looking for but generally mark go
back to my main point this data this
information this analysis is for you and
as particularly as portfolio holders you
is absolutely within your gift to liaise
with your assistant director liaise with
the business improvement team to get
what you want it to be obviously what
you have got here immediately
post-election is you have many of you've
inherited your previous portfolio
holders set of data what I would
encourage and one one caveat if you like
if we chop and change it every quarter
or if we chop and change it all the time
you do lose the impact of trend data
which is equally important so whilst it
is within your gift please have one eye
if you like on that impact potentially
being lost if we completely overhaul it
all the time it's not set in stone this
has continued to evolve over a point in
time and we have regularly had the
conversation in terms of it's too big
it's too small
can we find a Goldilocks size if you
like in terms of not too big or too
small
that achieves what you're seeking to
achieve but primarily it's for you yeah
thank you chair just in relation to to
the last performance indicator it was
one that members had asked for
historically is an indicator of the
number of people coming on to the
waiting list what priority so you can
draw analogies with for example
homelessness and you can also draw
analogies with people moving into
accommodation myself and the portfolio
of older for housing we've already
discussed a review off the performance
indicators for housing for the next four
years and we'll be conducting a workshop
to focus on them so if you have got any
views or opinions on what you would like
to see in relation to housing
performance then police the edge which
makes myself or or Council Osborne
well VZ
Gosselaar RC as well no I didn't know
did i okay castle Rosewall thank you
very much thank you I'm gonna consider
my hand slapped and I will opt out from
this point of receiving paper documents
because you're right there is an awful
lot of paper there so I will register
that opting out at some point I find
this really very very useful and for
example as a cabinet member for housing
I want to know how many's on the Housing
Register and how it's going on it's
going up or it's going down I also want
to know how many people for example are
in bed and breakfast whether that's
going up or going down
so I find this very very useful however
as gavin has already alluded to we are
doing a review to make sure that the
indicators that we've got on there are
the right indicators they are
informative and they are actually
serving a purpose so I do support this
perhaps the graphs don't need the graph
so much but I do like the comparison of
comparing with previous quarters even
with comparison with previous years so I
I still think we should continue with
this woman that's fine but the
information isn't information you
mentioned the other night you're talking
about number of houses built for HRA
this year if you look at the graph H do
one we have a target of two hundred and
ten for the three years 2017 to 2020 we
didn't build any in 1819 you've
identified some that are being built
this year but it doesn't tell us how
many short of the 210 we are the one
piece of information that would be
useful it doesn't mention yeah actually
you're absolutely right
and this is one area I've identified as
needed clarification it doesn't give the
right picture of where we are with our
development program on houses for our
housing stock so that's one area that we
will be definitely be looking at
yeah I agree with their counsel Osborne
I found it really useful over the past
year and and I seem to recall at full
council councillor Busby had a real go
about the graph and everything then so
the improvement that the team Karen and
the team have made over the past year is
really tangible so that it's a lot
better than it was still not perfect you
know and I think really accept that but
Karen has worked really closely with the
the 80s and the corporate managers to
try and make it more concise and more
relevant and I think you know that that
she's done a great job in doing it and
that'll continue on I'm sure under but I
do find the information particularly
customer services I was able to look at
it and be able to go to Sarah and say
why is this or what is that and and she
always had an answer obviously because
she was on top of it so it's really
useful really helpful and it's also
helpful for the public as well of those
people that are interested in these are
not great stats myself but it does sum
it up but it can be better and yes thank
you
I find the information regarding two
days lost through sickness whether short
term a long term very important I've got
a particular interest in health and
well-being on the mental health side
because it does affect all of us and it
affects our productivity now Rafi yeah
I first of all tend to agree with what
councilor Parker said with regard to the
production of this I mean it we would
come under a lot more criticism if we
didn't do it and since we're doing it I
think that Karen Cole does it rather
well there is the advantage that it
Flags up sort of problem areas and
for me CSO 6 and CSO 7 problem areas and
rather than actually look up
the fold-out sheets there's a thing on
page bottom of page 60 top of page 61
just an explanation of what's happening
and the reason it concerns me is that
for some of our residents and sometimes
it's our residents who need us most this
is their principal way of contacting us
and you know I just I still do not think
that it's acceptable that we have that
average time for answering calls and
that number of calls abandoned they've
caused abandoned presumably err because
it hasn't been answered very quickly and
so somebody hangs out and that's
somebody who found us up because they
wanted something or needed something and
I just don't think that that's
acceptable still I understand that lots
of work is being done to improve it but
it's been an issue for quite a while now
and it's not as bad to be fair as it has
been but I think that is still a big
concern for us this is the people that
we represent trying to contact us about
the services that we offer and things
that they need from us very good
answering the phone and if any of us
have actually tried to do it which I
have I've tried to use the main number
and it does take ages to get through
sometimes you get cut off sometimes you
don't get put through to the right
person or sometimes even the person on
the telephone doesn't seem to know who
it is you're after and in my particular
case it was quite a sitting member of
stuff and they didn't know who it was so
I really do think that you know it's
flagged up as a problem and we have to
really keep on top of this do something
about 7:00 thank you comment on this at
all well on counselor are theis a point
of course you know sole reason for being
is to be here for our constituents and
so
all we want to do is to make
improvements in the system and to
understand I and that is status that
it's work that will you know under as me
as the new portfolio holder I'll work
very closely with the with the offices
to try and improve all the while as best
as we can on that chair I think you know
what we're presenting here is the
quarter four reports I obviously don't
have particular answers to specific
points contained within at this stage
whilst on getting up and running what I
can say with regards to CSO so from
there since councillor Aarthi has
mentioned it quarter four was a
particularly challenging time for the
council as we know because it's when
council tax bills go out we also you
know we're preparing for elections
during that time so the system itself
was under strain but I accept our job is
to be here for our constituents and we
need to we need to make improvements
continually in that respect thank you I
just have one observation and that is on
page 82 SP o 1 SP o 2 we're presenting
this information that at the end of each
year I think it might be useful for both
of those performance measures if if we
can get some kind of in year position
because it would be good to know I think
we're within a year whether we're
meeting our targets in terms of
dwellings completed but also more
importantly with with SB o to the the
five-year land supply does fluctuate
within a year and we do need to be aware
of that and to be able to respond to
that in whatever way we can when we're
in a particular position with that at
the moment obviously so cancelar Theo
this is within your portfolio so perhaps
we could get some more granular stats
for those two during the year
thank you respond to that absolutely two
most important things I think what I've
taken on this portfolio is to provide an
up-to-date and
local plan and to ensure that we
maintain a five-year hazard supply thank
you are there any other questions from
the cabinet in which case capsule McCraw
do you have a question I just want to
stress I think I'm part of the scrutiny
position just how invaluable I think we
find this term scrutiny point of view
consistency of methodology an emerging
picture through the four quarters the
fourth quarter report is to my mind the
most valuable of all of these since
we've seen the picture emerging through
the last year and it's we've referred to
ourselves we could really see with
seeing what the end of year outcome is
so I would warn cabinet members who are
thinking of changing the methodology or
the method other nice things they're
reporting to be cautious in doing so the
data is useful there aren't many
subjects in here that haven't covered it
or scrutiny in the course of the last
year or two and some will come again but
this is an area this is a set of
documents where a scrutiny committee can
look at look at the overall performance
outcome and ask itself whether it needs
to rescrew tonigh the subject if we have
not already arranged to do so because we
use a cyclic or method so methodology
consistency I am a Stax man this stuff
is is meat and drink to us so we need
this and I would be I'd advocate caution
is all thanks very much
Thank You councillor and one last final
comment from me and that is on page 1 1
2 with regard to the number of garden
waste subscribers obviously this has
been something that that's been in the
national press given the suggestion that
this should be a free service and we're
finding that we continuing increase in
the number of subscribers so people are
clearly they understand the value of
paying for this service and are happy to
pay for it so I think this is a mess but
I know it's a message that through the
district councils Network we're feeding
back to government
and we do not see the need or the desire
to have free garden waste subscriptions
anyway on that note we've had the
recommendations proposed and seconded
may take a vote all those in favor
please thank you moving on now next one
paper BCA 19 5 the regulation of
Investigatory Powers Act mm a use of
legislation and updated policy I'll hand
over to councillor Parker take chair
this report is to inform councilors
about issues relevant to the use of the
regulation of investor ii Investigatory
Powers Act or Reaper mm and to provide a
refreshed policy for approval by way of
introduction for members Reaper provides
a legal framework for the council to use
covert methods of surveillance and
information gathering to assist in the
detection and prevention of crime in
relation to an Authority's core function
the legislation ensures that any
investigatory activity conducted by the
council is legal proportionate and
necessary it was introduced to ensure
that individuals rights are protected
while also ensuring that law enforcement
and security agencies including local
authorities have the powers they need to
do the job effectively some of the
changes I wish to draw members attention
to specifically are the creation of the
investigatory powers Commissioner's
Office or it go in September 27
following the abolishment of the office
of surveillance commissioners the
intelligence services Commissioner's
Office and the interception of
communications Commissioner's Office the
it Co is now responsible for the
judicial oversight of the use of direct
or covert surveillance by public
authorities throughout the United
Kingdom's who's been a change
effectively of regulator the two legal
office is responsible for acting as the
council senior responsible officer and
Reaper coordinator left the organisation
when the shared legal service was formed
although it's very unlikely for the
council's to use Reaper as confirmed by
H councils Nils statistical return over
the past years there was a recognition
that the existing joint reef
policy should be refreshed and the key
roles reassigned to the perfectly
appropriate offices a report was
recently presented to the senior
leadership team and the key roles of the
senior responsible offer officer the
Reaper coordinating officer and the
authorizing officers have now been
assigned and the details of those can be
found in Appendix one of the attached
policy in terms of performance
monitoring and training it coab have
adopted a more flexible approach to the
arrangements for inspections as it's
become apparent in recent years for a
variety of reasons which have included
reduced resources greater access to data
matching and over rather than covert law
enforcement that most authorities have
granted fewer or no recent surveillance
requests in November of last year 2018
it Co advised that based on the
information provided the council has
demonstrated a level of compliance that
removes for the present the requirement
for a physical inspection it will note
here that the last inspection was
carried out actually in 2015 it Co noted
that the draft joint policy document
being presented today was clear and
comprehensive and importantly that an
all training session has been organized
which took place in November of last
year which put the council in a position
to be able to apply the Act in the
lawful and efficient manner if the need
arose so chair I therefore recommend
that the refreshed joint
retha policy and the changes in
respective officer roles be approved and
the change in the judicial oversight in
the United Kingdom noted thank you Thank
You councillor may I have a second to
please
casseroles born members of the cabinet
any questions
Osbourne not so much question I think
it's a very good policy and I'm really
pleased to see it before us today and
however what I would like to say is that
we all know that in Weber we have a very
real problem with fly-tipping
and litter and things like although we
have the bigger
events of fly-tipping there's also the
smaller ones on a lot of our housing
developments with mattresses and SETI's
and electrical appliances all this which
impact on people's quality of life and
also on their health and safety and in
addition to this we are becoming more
and more aware in Sudbury that we a lot
of our play areas including the
brand-new BMX park in Bellevue is
suffering from graffiti and it's taken
the town community wardens a lot of
their time to clear it and clean it away
where they could be focused in focusing
on other areas and I'd very much like us
to see us use this policy to the full to
be very creative and proactive in how we
can use this to help reduce this impact
that it's having on people's lives you
know I often I've done it myself and I
don't know that I'm supposed to but I've
picked up a mattress myself and taking
it down to the dump because it's had to
wait so long to be removed and by the
time it gets removed you've got what
you've got the problem with rats as well
coming along so I really would like to
see us reuse this policy and try and
reduce the level of fly to pin and
litter in that we're suffering from
throughout the whole of bebo
Thank You mr. John Thank You councillor
Davis just a quick one and perhaps John
can can answer this many years ago when
I was a journalist I went undercover
with some Housing Benefit for
investigators and I was just wondering
if obviously this would cover this but
we've had no do we ever do or is that
outside Labour's remit in terms of
trying to catch benefit cheese thank you
very much that's certainly something
that we actually can consider I'm
speaking to one of the managers at the
SRP and looking at preventative fraud
techniques anyway and that's one area
where
we can possibly work together certainly
across if switch as well because
obviously share palm ship is the three
authorities that something we can
explore further as we move forward and
develop those relationships but
particularly around those sorts you tend
to find that we get reports that come in
in terms of fraud benefit they get the
tend to get passed off see to the DWP
who actually then do the investigations
themselves but there is a liaison and
there's a single point of contact access
the conduit between obviously giving the
benefit and also checking to make sure
it gets to the right people and yeah we
discussed this quite often that the
shared revenue partnership and the
actual benefit fraud is down to the
Department of Work and Pensions it's out
of our remit to be able to do that
however tenancy fraud is within our
remit to do it and we need to take this
up more and it has been discussed and
the partnership are looking at how they
can move this forward Thank You
councillor any other questions on this
Karthi hmm it's not really a question
it's just a comment page 137 and Cheers
when I read this horrified I was
horrified that we could be considering
someone who can establish or maintain a
personal or other relationship for the
covert purpose of using that
relationship to obtain information
sounds like all sort of spy movie stuff
but I think I was very sure that we've
never done this and if anybody wanted or
needed to do such a thing that would
need not only special training but
special authorization the very special
course of action and very
authorities have gone down this route
some of the London boroughs I think that
perhaps historically have but it needs
to be really carefully managed there are
special dispensations but there also
requires a lotta thority to go down that
route and actually maintain the records
to ensure you I do diligence in terms of
open transparency but it's an area that
we probably would never ever go down as
a council councillor Parker yeah thanks
nod just expand on that if I can as well
I mean the report itself is about noting
the change in the regulatory function
etc etc however I think it's important
to stress and indeed the report does
stress around that this is the option of
last resort to use to use the powers
available under under here so I'm very
heavily regulated and and for all the
right reasons as well but you know a
nuclear option if you like in the in the
armament yeah okay thank you everyone no
further questions then we've had the
recommendation person seconded all those
in favor thank you
the next item bc a 19-6 the end of year
risk position statement and progress
report and the revisions to the risk
management strategy again councillor
Parker excellent thank you come on a
chair again I think chair if I might I
think for the benefit of of new members
on on the cabinet I just have a
refresher an overview of risk management
process if we might so the council's
significant risk register is reviewed at
quarterly senior leader team senior
leadership team workshops where each
risk is reviewed in terms of direction
of travel scoring and mitigation still
to complete potential new risks are also
discussed each risk on the register is
owned by a member of the senior
leadership team and following each
workshop session they will liaise with
respective League member to ensure
they're up to date on the rest position
the register is reported half yearly to
cabinet for
approval and this report provides
cabinet with the end-of-year significant
risk register and also a summary of the
work of the audit and risk management
services team during the last year the
register or this particular register
that we're reporting on is at the end of
March of this year so some risks may
have changed since this time and another
review is due to be undertaken at the
end of this month obviously on the
register itself you'll see that each
risk tells a story across the page
starting from the initial inherent
scoring through to the current position
and ending with the target score and
outstanding actions to help achieve it
risks are character categorized under
five themes for ease of use the report
that accompanies the register provides
an overview of the register as at the
31st of March of this year 2019 the
current risk register has 27 risks a 16
are scored as medium 9 high and 2 very
high since the previous report to
cabinet 1 risk has been removed Quarter
3 which was we may fail to deliver the
financial projection set out within the
be MBS business plan this risk and
associated actions is now being
monitored via the relevant operational
risk register operational risk registers
are in place for all service areas and
are updated on at least a quarterly
basis a system directors liaise with
their respective corporate managers
regarding any potential risks that may
need escalating to the significant risk
register more project which risk
registers has been created and monitored
with the operational registers located
on connect in addition to the
end-of-year risk register also attached
is the risk management strategy which is
undergone its annual review minor
revisions have been made relating to the
risk matrix the risk appetite section
has also been amended under the
operational and service delivery risk
section approval from cabinet is being
sought for those amendments and finally
whilst reporting dates for future risk
reports to cabinet have been slightly
altered to ensure they align with
performance and Finance reports
so unless there are any other questions
on ask for a secondary to that thank you
I will sorry I lastly the cabinet
they've got any questions but first I
want to make the observation that I
think the information in this report is
of immense value to us all as cabinet
members and I think I think it's I find
it incredibly useful so any questions
councillor Busby well you won't be
surprised AB perhaps I could ask the
cabinet members which risk is the one
that concerns them the most without
looking referring to their papers to see
how good the information is I'll go with
that
dear delivery of an up-to-date and valid
local plan and maintaining a five year
nursing supply so delivery of housing Oh
Rosewall yeah I can ask that too and I
haven't cheated and looked at the papers
the HRA business case is obviously the
one that is the biggest risk to me and
for me the leading term financial
situation okay good well done swats
what's my understanding these billing
reports a page if we go to page 153
sorry buddy it's 5.2 thing to business
growth and an increased productivity now
we have three group three kind of broad
chart whatever it is the original scores
show that they were all in the red 2a 2b
2c and 2d was even though in the dark
red almost the blood-red the current
scores are now all in the orange which
is the same as the target scores but it
doesn't kind of say that we've achieved
target or it still seems to be a risk
so I don't understand why we've achieved
the target and there's no kind of
reference to it or or what do we try and
change the target to reduce the risk
even further or how have we achieved the
target data
okay John yes yeah thank you Joe happy
to answer in terms of going from left to
right if you like or the actual register
and also within the report what we're
trying to establish is actually by
telling the story and what we're trying
to aspire to so ultimately in terms of
the target schools we are looking to try
and reduce the likelihood and impact
through a number of mitigations some of
the nature of the risks that we have on
that register are difficult to do it but
we need to manage those in a very
proactive way obviously the assistant
directors basically the risk owners are
talking to your good cells in terms of
getting that dialogue and engagement to
see whether we can make further
improvements but the idea of this
register is really to basically show
members how we're actually managing
those risks forum is a safe from the
inherent side right through to the
current and the residual stuff and those
target scores which we're trying to
achieve and aspire to so ideally we are
trying to move those scores in a
downwards direction but as I said some
of those risks will remain the same
score
because purely the nature of the risk
itself and and also it's it's no no bad
thing with someone they doesn't imply
that there's there's a problem it just
recognizes the fact that particular on
those that you've identified to the
business growth and increased
productivity that that that will always
be the risk level of those particular
issues and but we will be managing them
in accordance with that casler Parker
thank you I mean I've you know I'm quite
I'm really enjoying this my my new
problem actually is as portfolio I hold
for this and I you know really sort of
got into the maintenance of this and and
you know in its simplest terms because
you're you're right there's a lot of
colors here and for somebody who is
colorblind themselves this is quite
challenging actually with reds and
greens particularly but it in itself
risk management is you know it's it's
something that he's universally
recognized and and and worked upon and
there are three elements to risk
management it's quite simply you
identify the risk you analyze the risk
and then you mitigate the risk and that
is it in its in its simplest terms and
that is what these these graphs are
showing and obviously in the second
phase that when you analyze the risks
you know you break those down into into
subsections so it's that risk is it is
it is it a minor risk is it a moderate
risk is it a severe risk and then you
put the mitigation factors into play
so all this report list is doing is
showing precisely that one thing that I
think we must never lose sight of course
is that you cannot ever eliminate risk
all you can do is manage it and and I'm
actually at first glance you know there
might be some work that might need to be
undertaken in terms of the you know the
way that we present possibly but at
first glance I accept that you know
there's an awful lot of information
there but essentially if we bear that in
mind that all we're trying to do there
is to manage that risk and ultimately to
mitigate it but understand at all times
you could never actually do away with
that actually these these are really
really useful useful graphs in my
opinion thank you thank you
any other questions okay then we'll take
a vote all those in favor of the
recommendation please thank you
right we will now move back to item 7 on
your agenda the forthcoming decisions
list you've all are you about to get a
paper copy of that for the last time
ever because it is emailed to everyone
and it is available and on the Internet
okay so looking forward through through
the list does anyone have any comments
on anything we've got coming up to
council joint local plan later this
month
we've got the cabinet for July here
we've got a number of papers coming up
there but I don't think there's anything
that we were unaware of all its
controversial or anything that's been
admitted I can't see anything with we've
forgotten down any comments anyone
nope
go Ferrari as far as I'm aware unless
you know something I don't
I mean that there was a little
possibility that it might have to go to
the Dubai incident June but we've had
the steering group meetings and as far
as I'm aware unless you know something I
don't
we're on track and the papers should
come out or either end of this week or
beginning of next week I can answer that
sound for having had the conversation
yesterday yes so members should receive
a copy of the papers on Friday the
agenda itself is then being published on
Monday fine o'clock by five o'clock on
Monday so you'll get your when twice but
you'll get them in advance and yes it's
going to reach a full council which is
the following week which is good because
I've been telling my parishes that'll be
coming through to full council this
month and being going out to
consultation next month so everyone is
eagerly awaiting it and so they can
provide their their comments on it so
that's that's that I think everything
else is fine from from my point of view
any other comments nope okay then
well if that's if that's that then we're
all happy with with that forthcoming
decisions list I'm going to draw the
meeting to close thank you everyone for
coming to our first cabinet meeting the
next meeting Thursday length of July at
5:30 evening meeting thank you everyone